[Música]
si son como yo seguramente inician su
día así
like
un celular hay obvio voy a entrar este
like comentar etiqueta las dos amigas de
siempre
si me lo gano lleva wey número de 2.365
al que participó pero intentar no cuesta
nada sí sí me lo gano
qué bárbara que guapa light
qué horror hay no
qué horror lo que está haciendo en el
mundo qué impotencia
ya que like
si son como yo ven este tipo de
contenido a levantarse mientras
desayunan cuando comen literal a todas
horas y a diario
pero saben realmente
la cantidad de información a la que
están expuestos
porque yo no pero seguramente es
demasiada y cuánta desinformación
realmente analizas o utilizas y no
solamente le das like
realmente cuántas veces han utilizado el
celular y han visto cosas que al final
de cuentas no son utilizables
así que si pareciera ser que la
información que nos llega a día a día
tiene el único propósito de distraernos
y no necesariamente de informarnos como
población
y no no voy a darles una teoría
conspiración al de que nos están
controlando o manipulando sino de darles
entender a todos y cada uno de ustedes
el rol esencial y trascendental que
tienen en el contexto social político e
incluso económico que impacta su entorno
y la de los demás y que muchas veces
preferimos dejar de lado o simplemente
no involucrarnos no me creen
quieren ver se los voy a comprobar si
les dijera que tengo cinco cajas llenas
de boletas para registrar a todos los
interesados como voluntarios para
recoger basura en un río de la ciudad
cuántos de ustedes se registran
está bien pero si les dijera que en esas
boletas tengo pues muchísimas para
registrar a todos los interesados a una
rifa para ganar un auto último modelo
del año sin costo alguno cuántos de
ustedes le entran
pues claro
porque solemos priorizar el beneficio
personal mucho más y a costa del
beneficio colectivo pues quién es ella
quien se cree porque me está diciendo
estas cosas no soy nadie soy una simple
ciudadana promedio de unos 56
centímetros de altura que sigue
estudiando y que entre muchas cosas le
encanta actuar si he hecho teatro
musical pero también me encanta actuar
en sociedad
siempre ha sido muy activa curiosa
exigente pero más que inteligente
me considero observadora siempre en
camino a la universidad presencial tiene
que cruzar una calle para ir por los
antojitos simplemente el camión o
comprar ese café reparador en suman
exámenes esta calle estaba frente a la
puerta principal de la universidad y
cada que pasaba por ella les juro que
era una aventura porque ni en la selva
había que trepar ni esquivar tanto bueno
si exagere pero la calle un asco estaba
llena de baches por las orillas estaba
levantada simplemente esa que yo no
estaba ni derecha y digo yo no tenía
coche
sami que verdad
pero estaba frente a la universidad que
representaba universidad donde estudió y
por la que transitaba mañana tarde y
noche a diario
un día como cualquier otro llegando a la
escuela mi grupo amigos está platicando
y comentaron acerca de un estudiante un
chavo que había llegado en muletas
porque había tenido un accidente al
cruzar esa calle el día anterior
quedé verdaderamente impactada y no
podía dejar de cuestionarme que podía
hacer yo al saber esa información
después de conocer esa historia que
podría estar en mis manos que podría ser
yo con ella y ojo aquí porque en esa
conversación yo visualice solo tres
tipos de personas se acuerdan que les
dije que me gustaba actuar pues
prepárense porque no les dije si era
buena así que ustedes juzgarán la
persona uno comenzó hoy no qué horror
andar en muletas por todo el campus ay
no no no no no oye pero sabes cómo
estuvo
es que sabes que ese hábito seguro se
cruzó no se fijó esto en sus
consecuencias
la persona 2
muletas no ósea así que no lo dejaron en
silla de ruedas o parapléjico claro eso
es que sabes que en esa calle pasan muy
rápido sí sí yo yo también lo he hecho
por eso digo que un seguro fue muy
rápido no alcanzó a frenar y se lo llevó
tantito
y muletas
o sea pero entonces aplicó el seguro
como estuvo el golpe no es saben que es
que lo que sea acá que ya urge que
arreglen esa calle
y para esto me contestaron ay nena pues
ni el paso peatonal tiene pintado como
no querías que lo atropellaran
y fue entonces que me pregunte pues a
cuantos más habrán atropellado ya
de camino a mi casa no puede dejar de
pensar en el accidente que había tenido
este estudiante y giraba constantemente
en mi cabeza la imagen de esa calle sin
arreglar y sin pintar que tanto podría
cambiar nuestras vidas un paso peatonal
en zona escolar
quien tendrá la facultad de mandarlo a
arreglar terminando mi tarea decidí
escribir una carta al gobierno local
en pocas palabras abrí mi computadora y
te quiero con todo mi enojo e impotencia
mi preocupación sobre la seguridad que
implicaba la calle lo que sucedía y lo
que seguiría sucediendo si no lo
arreglaban
para esto eran meras notas en mi
computadora que no sabía a dónde
enviarlas porque no encontraba el correo
de la persona ni el contacto directo en
mi impotencia decidí imprimir muchísimas
cartas con una cuadrícula para poner
nombre y firma al día siguiente me fui a
la parada del camión donde supuestamente
habían atropellado a este chavo y empezó
a compartir mi preocupación y la
historia de lo que sucedió con tal de
empatizar con quien me escuchara y al
terminar le pedía que me firmara la
petición para arreglar la calle muchos
firmaron pero no se imaginan que era un
activismo de película no se veía nada
bonito nada más veían a una mocosa de
metro y medio sudando con la mochila más
grande que su torso acercándose a la
gente diciéndole no tienes pluma no te
preocupes yo tengo te tienes que
encargar aquí en mi espalda no te
propuesta me agacho más ok yo firmo este
no tu firma le está escena se repetía en
los pasillos en los salones en la
cafetería y frente a la puerta principal
después de un rato
ya llevaba un montón de hojas arrugadas
pero firmadas de ciudadanos y ciudadanas
que coincidían conmigo y alumnos de la
universidad que pues algunos si me
alentaban a que siguiera uno que otro me
apoyó porque creía que pueda lograrlo
pero siendo muy sincera hubo mucha gente
por no decir que demasiada que me vio de
manera despectiva
y escéptica
y los pocos de esas personas que
realmente firmaban me decían
pues la esperanza es lo último que muere
no
en esos momentos les juro que era cuando
más pena me daba cuando más
insignificante me sentía no solo por
interrumpir pidiendo firmas sino porque
no le veían una utilidad a lo que estaba
haciendo me daban a entender que no
habría manera de lograr lo que no habría
firmas suficientes que nada sería
suficiente con cada mueca de toda esa
gente
verdaderamente sentía que me extinguía
pero seguí ya había comenzado y eso
siempre es lo más difícil al terminar el
día me adentré al pasillo donde sabía
que se encontraba la oficina del rector
y cuando vi que estaba la secretaria me
armé de valor y le dije que quería ver
al rector que era muy importante y que a
qué hora me recibía
seguramente la secretaria creyó que
estaba loca que era una creída o una
altanera pero me recibió justo se
encontraba desocupada el rector y me
pasaron a su oficina
comencé platicándole de la misma manera
en la que le contaba a la gente de
afuera mi preocupación y la terrible
situación de la calle no tardé ni un
segundo en sacarle esas firmas que
comprobaban y respaldaban mi
preocupación con toda esa gente también
cabe recalcar que no se lo deje nada más
en el escritorio le pedí de manera
directa y urgente que me ayudará a
arreglar esa calle
imaginen que tan desesperada me veía que
al instante sacó su celular
cuántas veces usamos leemos o escuchamos
información
y no hemos hecho absolutamente nada
vivimos en un mundo tan interconectado y
lleno de información que se nos está
haciendo fácil dejar de prestar atención
la información puede estar al alcance de
todas y de todos pero está en nosotros
su observación y acción para el bien
común qué pasaría
si en eso weiss en lugar de meterle
esfuerzo tiempo y emoción
qué tipo realmente no los vamos a ganar
o realmente saben si no son falsos y los
utilizáramos ese esfuerzo emoción y
tiempo en cosas que sí hicieron un
cambio
si la humanidad ha logrado evolucionar
gracias a los y las que se han
involucrado para impulsarlos los cambios
porque creemos que en esta era digital
este tipo de participación activa ya no
es necesaria para seguir evolucionando
si a una persona se le apaga el coche
frente al tuyo en el semáforo no
etiquetas a tus amigos para ayudar a
empujarlo
cuando sabemos que hubo un asesinato por
motivos raciales o un feminicidio
si ves la información y la compartes
pero sabemos que se llega mucho más
rápido a la justicia cuando ves a la
gente exigiendo justicia y marchando en
las calles y perdónenme pero aqui en
mexico cuando los edificios se
derrumbaron no los vimos levantarse con
likes
lo virtual está en lo real y lo real
también está lo virtual el internet es
vital
pero no confundamos jamás activismo o
participación como mera interacción
digital no creamos que por compartir una
opinión crítica o firma en una
plataforma será siempre suficiente
necesitamos hacernos presentes
todos ustedes podrían saber
perfectamente en un clic cuánto tiempo
invierten en internet a diario un
desglose específico en cada red social y
el tipo de contenido que consumen pero
muy pocos seguro saben que han hecho o
contabilizan el tiempo que han invertido
en sus comunidades como ciudadanos y
ciudadanas de pie
honestamente que tanto has podido hacer
con tu celular
resulta que el rector no sacó su
teléfono para seguirme darme likes o
compartir mi recolección de firmas en
ese preciso momento se comunicó con el
gobierno local y si yo sabía que había
una ligera probabilidad de que él
tuviera el contacto porque investigando
encontré que los rectores de las
universidades son las personas que
directamente representan a la comunidad
universitaria y que si está en sus
deberes velar por nuestra seguridad
a los 15 días de esa llamada la calle ya
se estaba arreglando
y crearme no es un paso peatonal no son
los baches arreglar una calle no
significa nada sino el saber que esa
ridícula de metro y medio logró impulsar
que se arreglará
me abrió los ojos y me hizo entender que
definitivamente nunca ha importado el
tamaño ni de la persona ni de la acción
sino el tamaño de la convicción por
cambiar las cosas
tu falta de interés está limitando no
sólo tu interacción te está extinguiendo
y está alejándose de todo aquello que
amerita tu participación
seguro han escuchado eso de si no eres
tú quien si no es ahora cuando está
frase yo la escuché en una conferencia
que dio la actriz emma watson ante las
naciones unidas y resulta que antes
también le había expresado el ex
presidente estadounidense ronald reagan
me atrevo a decir que muchos años usted
esta frase como guía
pero siempre sentí que le faltaba algo
y hasta hace un poco tiempo me permití
complementarla
porque si no lo haces tú entonces que lo
va a hacer si no lo haces ahora hasta
cuándo y si no te informas
cómo vas a lograrlo
yo decir gutiérrez hago mi mayor
esfuerzo para que ese aparato en lugar
de quitarme tiempo haga hacerlo valer
que la información valiosa y confiable
que leo llegue a más gente para que
entonces las cosas importantes nos
preocupen lo suficiente y hagamos algo
al respecto
así que por favor cuando creas que algo
es importante es porque importa y si no
te involucras si no levantas la mano
créeme cuando te digo que a nadie más le
va a importar
central e infórmate y observa apropia de
tus causas y empieza a actuar
pero en tu realidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]